what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I want to have a discussion about
Marvel character or I guess power
classifications because in the future of
this channel I'll be making statements
like strife is Omega level x-man is
Omega level and so it's important that
you guys understand what it is that I
mean when I make this statement so that
you guys can have some context in the
understanding of where these characters
stand in Marvel Comics so in the Marvel
Universe they have four main
classifications that particularly
pertain to mutants now the upper echelon
classifications pertain to cosmic
entities but nonetheless with the the
four main classifications what we have
is gamma Beta Alpha and Omega in that
order now gamma mutants are mutants who
for the most part have powers but
they're just really weak and nobody
cares about them beast is a really good
example beast has enhanced agility he
can lift ten tons but for all intents
and purposes with regards to his mutant
abilities he pretty much sucks I mean
he's really really smart in the realm of
biochemistry and genetics and
electronics but in terms of its place in
the x-men he's more or less kind of like
a cheerleader Angel is the same way I
mean usually just has these feathery
wings and you can fly around now of
course that's angel before he took on
the form of Archangel at the hands of
apocalypse but nonetheless for the most
part he's just a really kind of weak
character beta level characters are
characters who have powers that are
strong and they're formidable but
there's weaknesses a weakness maybe that
they can't control it Cyclops is a good
example Cyclops has an optic blast that
has a power that's ranged from being
able to knock a person unconscious to
being able to slice a mountain in half
it really just kind of depends on the
situation the context of the comic that
his powers and being used in but
nonetheless he has a very powerful optic
blast and I think it's actually a
theorized or the way the comic is set up
his eyes are actually a portal to a
different dimension and so it just
channels the energy of that dimension
into our dimension but nonetheless I'm
not going to go into the big discussion
about that I'll show you that for a
Cyclops discussion at some point in time
but nonetheless
fact that he cannot control his optic
glass make that a weakness he doesn't
have any kind of mental control over all
the control for his optic glass comes
from his visor take somebody like
Wolverine for example Wolverine has an
enhanced healing factor but he can't
control it these are flaws that are
perceived in the world of Marvel Comics
with regard to these characters despite
how powerful their powers may be or what
kind of exotic energies they may wield
because of their powers now alpha level
mutants are characters who have powers
that are on par with beta level
characters but they have control over
them so this is where you find
characters like Charles Xavier or Emma
Frost or Magneto
there are extremely powerful characters
but they have a mental on/off switch and
they can refine and control their powers
to even the most nuanced degrees now
Omega level is where things get crazy
these are characters who have powers
that are so extreme and they have such
refined control over them that they are
for the most part unchallenged aside
from a separate group of people this is
where you find characters like onslaught
or I would argue apocalypse and I might
even take a step further and argue that
magneto is an omega-level mutant this is
also where you find characters like
Vulcan Gabriel Summers he's a third
Summers brother in addition to Cyclops
and havoc these are characters who are
able to manipulate cosmic energies are
able to manipulate exotic energies or
can manipulate the powers of other
people take for example someone like a
lick sir
elixir has the ability to alter the
biochemical structure of other people
and therefore he can effectively turn
their powers off now when it comes to
beyond Omega this is where you find for
the most part cosmic entities and maybe
a handful of characters or I guess
mutants in the Marvel Universe this is
where you find cosmic entities like
eternity and death The Living Tribunal
the one above all and with regards to
mutants this is where you find
characters like Mad Jim Jasper's and
Franklin Richards now there's some
debate here
with regards to the Phoenix force at the
peak of her power and the reason why is
because Galactus is considered to be an
elemental part of the universe he's more
or less beyond Omega level and at the
peak of her powers Jean Grey was able to
really kind of unleash hell on a park
I'm sorry I want Galactus there really
wasn't much he could do against her so
you know there's some debate here but
the reason why I choose not to use Jean
Grey and the Phoenix force as a as an
Omega level character or beyond Omega
level is because Jean Grey's power or
her ability to reach Omega level is
contingent on her tapping into the
Phoenix force without the Phoenix force
Jean Grey is your garden-variety
telepath and telekinetic a character
like quinton choir for example Kidd
Omega who was an extremely powerful
telepathic and telekinetic mutant could
easily wreak havoc on Jean Grey if she
was not using the Phoenix force now
there are a couple clarifications that I
need to make here there are characters
or entities that have been introduced to
the Marvel Comics that I choose not to
use as being beyond Omega level most
notably a character like the Beyonder
the Beyonder was for all intents and
purposes the entire universe of his own
dimension formed into one being he was
in effect his own universe and he had
powers that were incredibly unstoppable
if I got think the only person who could
stop him was the one above all who like
I said before is for all intents and
purposes God in the Marvel Comics but I
choose not to use the Beyonder because
he's not native to our universe and when
it comes to the idea of Omega level
beyond omegle Omega level even
classifications that kind of thing I
prefer to stick with the homegrown crown
I'm really not a big fan of the idea of
other characters coming from outside the
outside of our universe and and then
hopping on to the Omega level train just
because when it comes to extra
dimensional beings their dimensions vary
widely there are some that have these
really basic dimensions that are much
like our own they're there some that
hail from dimensions that are so extreme
that just by the very nature of their
dimension the characters have evolved to
such a level that they have
dream abilities that make them
omega-level characters so and even I
hope this all made sense I hope it comes
out understandable if it does let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace